[Music]
and welcome back to this Hannity special
for over 25 years
Operation Christmas Child has spread
Christmas cheer to children in need all
over the world the project is part of
the Christian relief organizations
Samaritan's Purse and unbelievably it is
collected over a hundred and sixty-eight
million gifts for children in more than
a hundred and sixty countries in
territory Shan recently sat down with
CEO of Samaritan's Purse Franklin Graham
here it is he right now is the CEO
Samaritan's Purse our good friend
Franklin Graham how are you sir good to
see you sir you should know thank you
such an incorrigible child to your poor
father look at you've turned out okay I
had the pleasure one year of going on a
trip with you and what was amazing about
it is in this box is like heaven for all
these kids know and it makes such a
difference you can't believe what a
difference it makes you know it Shawn
what we ask is when a person packs a box
right put the the Box boy or girl but
pray before you send us the Box just
pray for the child is going to get the
box I don't know who's gonna get the box
God does but I want every child to know
that God loves them I want every child
to know that God is real that he cares
for them and and I want them to know the
true meaning of Christmas and that is
that God sent His Son Jesus Christ to
this earth to save us from our sins this
is why this is poor boy right you got a
soccer ball you got just some toys and
some and then you also say put in simple
stuff like a toothbrush toothbrush but
put a letter in there to the child put
your picture in there because we want
the child to see and this happens to be
my youngest son who just got out of the
military after 16 years in special
operation laughs I know you're proud of
him so he's come to work with me
proud of that but these are just simple
items but it means everything in the
world of these kids but at the same time
Shawn it opens up a door for us to be
able to just share God's love with them
and you and your family went with us you
saw for yourself I'll be honest to see
the reaction I mean my Christmas is you
know it was a bicycle something really
big but to see the reaction of the kids
faces I mean it kind of it kind of takes
your breath away in a lot of ways I
guess we take for granted right maybe
it's natural we do all that we have
we're very very blessed nation now but
this is a this is a way that a family
can do something for another family
halfway around the world and it's so
simple and these are not expensive items
but for most children's the only gift
they've ever had in their life is crazy
and it's just it's just opens up a door
where we can talk to them and care for
they they light up like nothing I've
ever seen you how many boxes we do you
think you'll deliver this year this year
where would be a little north of 11
million boxes and what's your record so
far this will be probably the records
every year it grows and it grows every
year yeah a few hundred thousand
sometimes more so for people at home
they get a boxer's you know you can buy
a plastic one like this one here or you
know we push you boxes we provide them
we have by the boxes now I didn't know
that the boxes we also have great paper
boxes the plastic ones are better Sean
those and you wrap them it's another
gift
yeah and it's long after these toys are
worn out they still have the box I'll
have the box and I can busy kids you get
you get a present for a kid and then all
of a sudden they'd like the Box more
than the president Larry and so how do
people do this that's if they will go to
bingo to Samaritan's Purse or build our
website we show them how to pack a box
the items that we put in a box for a
girl or a boy and things just suggested
items and then we
the instructions on where to take the
Bhakra how to mail about how many
countries do you go to usually a year
yourself because you do you deliver a
lot of these I will go to a handful of
countries right we go to a hundred in
over 20 countries with the thinking of
representatives in all these countries
every country we have a national
leadership team that is responsible for
taking the shoeboxes and then
distributing them out to the churches we
deliver the boxes Shawn through churches
in these various countries and so let's
say our country gets a hundred thousand
boxes a particular country all right
that national leadership team is
responsible for then dividing that
hundred thousand boxes among the various
churches and then we have a program
suggested program but more importantly
we have another program after this is
over with it's a discipleship program
for the children that want to know more
about God learn more it's a 12 lesson
discipleship program and this past year
we had a little over 4 million children
well take a 12 lesson course this year
we'll have a little over 5 million
taking this course but it's just see
you're trying to make up for all the
trouble you caused your dad this is your
way of saying you know I'm trying to
make up for being the incorrigible
troublemaker that drove the Reverend
Billy Graham nuts but my mother didn't
let me get by with nothing I hate to
tell you but I was a lot more
incorrigible than you but I know that's
for another day this is a great cause go
to Samaritan's Purse dot org Samaritan's
Purse
thank you for what you do for these kids
every year it's amazing and thank you
Shawn for the appreciates but the word
out well thank you sir great to see you
good to see you god bless